ce que me rendormir entend tout le monde
mais quand tu en scène surtout quand il
faut bouger ou même dormir ou même pour
le manque de nourriture
il n'y a pas de ce qu'on a besoin donc
c'est compliqué de les sortir de cette
précarité et de les mettre à la c'est
pas normal aujourd'hui en france en 2021
des français et des hommes et des femmes
se retrouvent dans des tentes à dormir
dehors
[Musique]
moi ça fait quand même des annexions la
rue donc il ne m'a rien gros ras-le-bol
le dhj de vie quoi moi je travaille dans
un restaurant à la base mais avec le co
vide et ben ça fait tout s'est remis sur
toi aussi je pense dans cette galère à
cause de ça donc j'espère que quand un
navire russe il appartient
[Musique]